jean-françois d'abord il faut dire qu'il
ya eu de nombreuses manifestations des
manifestations sans précédent dans les
grandes villes c'est une campagne
électorale qui aura qui a pour ainsi
dire était inédite
ouais écouter en fait il faut savoir que
le contexte de cette élection
présidentielle là c'est que ça se
produit trois mois jour pour jour après
l'élection parlementaire qui a eu donc
au mois de décembre une élection qui a
donné lieu à des soupçons de fraude
vraiment important c'est à dire que des
fraudes sur une large échelle et ça ça a
poussé vous le savez des dizaines de
milliers de personnes à descendre dans
les rues c'est vraiment de réaction
qu'on n'avait jamais vu enrichi en
russie en tout cas pas depuis au moins
20 ans pas depuis l'arrivée de vladimir
poutine au pouvoir certainement pas et
personne n'a pu voir n'avait pu voir
venir en fait cette réaction parce que
les russes ont plutôt connu pour être un
peu apathique au niveau politique c'est
pas des gens qui se mobilisent beaucoup
ainsi ils ont très mal vécu les années
de chaos de cons suivi la fin de l'urss
les associer à boris eltsine et les gens
recherchent essentiellement la stabilité
c'est ça qui voulait donc vie
effectivement ce mouvement là personne
ne l'a vu venir et c'est dans ce
contexte là que se déroule ces élections
actuellement c'est sûr que tout le monde
aura l'oeil est ce qu'il y aura ou non
des fraudes et sur des tentatives de
fraudes c'est ce que tout le monde
surveille cette fois ci maintenant avec
60 % d'appuis selon les sondages la des
meilleures poutines finalement n'a pas
ce n'est pas beaucoup de considération
pour ses opposants
m'écouter effectivement les sondages
donnent gagnant probablement dès le
premier tour les sondages faut toujours
s'en méfier un petit peu on a eu des
surprises lors du du premier demeurent
des élections de décembre cela dit
effectivement il a une confortable
avance faut savoir quand même que
d'abord le terrain de jeu et pas
tellement et gazière poutine ouvre
finalement tous les journaux télévisés
en faisant en montrant qu'il est un
homme très occupé
avec son boulot de premier ministre il
est partout et il occupe tout l'espace
et les autres candidats ont très très
peu de place ça c'est une première chose
deuxièmement faut savoir que les
candidats qui se présentent en fait ce
sont des candidats qui ont déjà été en
quelque sorte pré approuvés par le
kremlin c'est une opposition nos
positions qu'on appelle ici systémique
une opposition un peu molle c'est des
gens qui systématiquement par exemple au
parlement vont toujours ratifié a prouvé
à tous les projets de loi qui sont
déposés par le kremlin donc c'est pas
des opposants durs si on peut dire donc
les gens qui ont manifesté dans la rue
ne se reconnaissent absolument pas dans
l'est dans le choix des candidats qui
leur sont qu'il aurait présentées donc
ces gens là finalement ont plutôt donné
comme mot d'ordre de voter pour tout le
monde sauf poutine